Fundamentalismo, narcotráfico, terrorismo,
lucha de guerrilla... no importa el nombre
que utilicemos porque creo que hay un
amplio consenso en que todos estos
grupos son los malos.
Ahora bien, la gran pregunta es ¿Cómo
combatirlos? ¿Cómo vencerles? O, en términos
de Star Wars ¿Cómo impedir que Darth
Sidious, el Emperador, se haga para
siempre con el control de toda la galaxia?
- "Su arrogancia le pierde, maestro Yoda".
Pues bien, en los últimos tiempos
parece que la respuesta más normal y
desde luego la que piden muchas personas
es la estrategia de utilizar toda la
fuerza disponible: ejércitos, bombardeos,
boicots comerciales, diplomáticos...
Vamos, lo que viene a ser un escenario de
guerra total. El problema amigos y es que
aunque estas acciones muchas veces
pueden ser necesarias, casi siempre
nos olvidamos de una parte esencial de
la estrategia, una parte menos llamativa
pero que es imprescindible para derrotar
a los malos
De hecho, en muchas ocasiones, si sólo
utilizamos la fuerza, el resultado, si es
que lo hay, puede incluso ser
contraproducente. En este vídeo,
sin ir más lejos, vamos a ver algunos
casos de grandes victorias contra los
"malos" en las que sí, se utilizó la
fuerza, pero ésta no fue ni con mucho la
verdadera protagonista del éxito.
Y aquí, tenemos la primera pregunta
clave ¿A que parte de la estrategia nos
estamos refiriendo? Pues... amigos,
precisamente a la que impide que los
malos puedan hacerse con el apoyo
popular, que al fin y al cabo es lo que
necesitan para reclutar a los
milicianos o a los terroristas y hacerse
también con recursos para llevar a cabo
sus siniestros planes. Hablamos de la
parte de la estrategia que pasa por
buscar lo que podemos llamar el
empoderamiento económico. Puede
parecernos, ojo, que este tipo de cosas no
son importantes para vencer a estos
grupos, pero en este vídeo vamos a
demostrar que sí lo son.
Por cierto, hemos preparado este vídeo a
partir de una sugerencia muy interesante
y muy bien documentada de nuestro
suscriptor Juan López, así que desde aquí
todo nuestro reconocimiento Juan.
Dicho esto, volvamos a la faena, en este caso para
desplazarnos hasta nuestro querido Perú
Vamos a suponer, amigos de VisualPolitik,
que nos hemos montado en el
DeLorean the Doc y hemos viajado atrás
en el tiempo
¿De acuerdo?
- "¿Con un de DeLorean? Yo creo que
sí vas a construir una máquina del
tiempo en un coche ¿por qué no hacerlo
con clase?".
Pues bien, estamos en 1990 en este
momento Sendero Luminoso, un grupo
terrorista de corte marxista leninista
controla la mayor parte del Perú.
Su poder es tan grande, atentos, que la
RAND Corporation, un potente Think Tank
de Washington orientado al análisis
militar y de seguridad le ha dicho al
mismísimo Departamento de Defensa de
los Estados Unidos que sendero luminoso
es una organización prácticamente
inexpugnable en los Andes y que en dos
años como mucho
este grupo se hará con el control de
todo el país.
- "Miembro de la comisión de
derechos humanos de la cámara diputados
hemos registrado en diversas
oportunidades denuncias de asesinatos masivos que
en algunos casos han involucrado hasta
100 personas muertas".
Pero... ¿Qué es Sendero
Luminoso? Y sobre todo ¿De dónde surge?
Para responder a estas preguntas tenemos
que mirar un poco más atrás en el
tiempo.
Vayamos hasta finales de la década de
los 70
En ese momento el Perú tenía un
problema: el ascensor social no
funcionaba. Es decir, me explico:
Sí nacías pobre, vivía pobres y tus hijas
y tus hijos serían pobres. Pero, ¿Por qué
ocurría esto? Pues, en buena medida
porque la burocracia impuesta por las
élites para proteger, claro,
su estatus y sus intereses, ahogaba
cualquier oportunidad de prosperar
En aquel momento en el Perú todo era
muy complicado: montar un negocio,
legalizar unas tierras heredadas, contratar
a alguien
El resultado es que los pobres estaban
condenados a vivir en la informalidad y
esto entraña muchísimos problemas.
Con la informalidad la seguridad jurídica
desaparece, no puedes pedir préstamos
por ejemplo para invertir en tu propio
negocio,
tampoco puedes acceder a contratos
públicos y así un largo etcétera,
etcétera, etcétera de cosas.
Fijaros, según las investigaciones del
prestigioso economista peruano Hernando
de Soto abrir un taller de confección
demoraba 289 días y costaba, ojo,  31
veces el salario mínimo mensual de la
época.
Vamos, que o eras rico o no tenías nada que hacer
- "Las gente ya también son
peruanos y todos debemos apoyarnos. Pero,
simplemente, la gente como tiene un
poco más de dinero ha hecho un cruce
para que la gente de acá, la gente más
humilde, no invada para allá".
Y había cosas aún peores.
Por ejemplo, legalizar un pedazo de
tierra podía llevar hasta 15 años.
¿Queréis saber cuál fue el resultado de
todo ello? Pues la exclusión económica
de muchísimas personas y la
imposibilidad fáctica de competir,
con lo que las élites conservaban sus
privilegios. Y este tipo de políticas
siempre genera muchísima desigualdad y,
sobre todo, muchísima frustración.
En ese momento surge Sendero Luminoso.
Es cierto, este grupo maoísta no nace
para luchar contra esta burocracia pero
sí es verdad que consigue crecer y ganar
apoyos gracias en buena medida a toda
esa frustración, a la pobreza ya la
desigualdad.
Claro que, la alternativa de Sendero
Luminoso era aún peor.
Y de eso se dieron cuenta muy pronto
muchos campesinos y trabajadores de las
áreas rurales que se negaban, por ejemplo, a
colectivizar la tierra que era algo que
defendía Sendero Luminoso.
Para defenderse
muchos de estos campesinos crearon
comités de autodefensa, las llamadas
DECAS rurales.
Pero, a pesar de algunos avances, apenas
se consiguió nada.
Entre otras cosas, porque no tenían el
apoyo del gobierno, no había
colaboración,
probablemente porque muchos de los
campesinos cocaleros.
- "Llego el momento
en qué venía Sendero, nos mataba,
venía alguien de la fuerza armada
también no mataba por qué nos confundía".
Y esto en sí mismo era un
problema grandísimo: por un lado los
militares combatían ciegos, no sabían
distinguir por ejemplo a un campesino de
un miembro de sendero luminoso lo que
provocó muchísimas víctimas inocentes
y esto a su vez se traducía, claro
está, en más apoyos para Sendero Luminoso.
El desastre era total.
Y cómo hemos visto todo apuntaba a que el
Perú caería pronto en manos de este grupo
terrorista. Pero... espera un momento porque
en la década de los 90 se probó una
nueva estrategia.
Por un lado, y gracias a un convenio
firmado con Estados Unidos, en el 91,
el gobierno de Perú reconoció que los
cocaleros no eran por definición
narcotraficantes sino simplemente
campesinos. Esto permitió que el
ejército no sólo les dejara en paz,
sino que incluso comenzará a cooperar
con las  DECAS. Por otro lado se inició un
ambicioso plan de reformas para favorecer
la integración económica de los
excluidos. Por ejemplo, se redujeron un 75
por ciento los trámites burocráticos que
bloqueaban el acceso a la actividad
económica; se reconocieron y se
formalizaron, ojo, cientos de miles de
propiedades y también se legalizaron
más de medio millón de empleos.
La situación la verdad cambio muy
rápido. Sendero Luminoso perdió
prácticamente cualquier apoyo y se
enfrentó una poderosa fuerza de choque
compuesta por más de 120 mil campesinos
y 30.000 soldados. Ahora tenían
motivación y medios suficientes para
luchar, entre otras cosas porque los
pobres ahora tenían la oportunidad de
prosperar.
Pues bien, en el 92 Sendero Luminoso era
ya historia y su líder Abimael Guzmán
estaba entre rejas.
Eso sí, por desgracia, amigos, este grupo
criminal dejó a sus espaldas casi 70
mil vidas perdidas
Y del Perú de los años 90 nos vamos
hasta principios del siglo 21.
David Petraeus ha sido uno de los generales más
importantes de Estados Unidos en los
últimos tiempos, incluso se habló de su
posible carrera a la Casa Blanca, aunque
amigos, esta posibilidad quedo truncada
en 2012 por un escándalo que le
obligó a dimitir: había compartido
información clasificada con su
biógrafa y amante. Pero no, no es esta
parte de su vida la que nos interesa.
La enorme popularidad que alcanzó este
General tuvo mucho que ver con sus
éxitos desde que en 2007 el presidente
George Bush le nombrara Comandante Jefe
de las tropas norteamericanas en Irak.
Y, ojo, porque el destino no era
precisamente fácil:  Irak era en esa
época un completo desastre, aún más
que hoy en día, y las tropas
estadunidenses se enfrentaban a muchísimos
problemas.
Pues bien, el general sabía que la cosa
no podían continuar así,
así que cambió por completo el enfoque
de la lucha y dejó a un lado la
estrategia inicial que consistía
simplemente en apostar por la abrumadora
superioridad militar. Y no sólo la dejó
a un lado, defendió abiertamente que limitar
la estrategia al campo militar era del
todo contraproducente
El general Petreaus, cambió el sistema de
juego y puso sobre la mesa la necesidad
de que el ejército estadounidense se
implicara con la sociedad y cobrase una
comprensión social, cultural y religiosa.
de los acontecimientos. Bajo sus órdenes
el ejército estadounidense comenzó a
cooperar con las fuerzas locales, con los
líderes tribales, empezó a prestar
atención a los problemas sociales y
económicos de la población, también
a la reconstrucción , etc.
Incluso, aunque parezca mentira, el
ejército norteamericano comenzó
diferenciar entre grupos terroristas y
organizaciones políticas, religiosas o
civiles. Hasta la llegada del General Petreaus
para los estadunidenses todos erán lo
mismo: enemigos.
El éxito de la nueva estrategia fue
total, el general dio la vuelta por
completo a la campaña. En poco tiempo
100.000 voluntarios iraquíes de
tribus que antes eran consideradas como
enemigas pasaron de enfrentarse a los
soldados estadounidenses a luchar codo
con codo con ellos.
Y la situación en Irak, claro, para el ejército yanqui
cambió por completo.
Bien, hace algo mas de quince años el
presidente de estados unidos George Bush
declaró la guerra global contra el
terrorismo.
Desde entonces, la gran potencia
norteamericana ha gastado cientos de
miles de millones de dólares en esta
cruzada y...es verdad, se han conseguido
muchos éxitos, entre ellos acabar con
más de 100 líderes terroristas.
Sin embargo, a pesar de ello hoy
occidente sigue siendo tanto o más vulnerable
ante los extremistas.
Así que, amigos, tal vez ha llegado la
hora de impulsar la parte de la
estrategia que no está relacionada con
la fuerza.
Por cierto, si quieres conocer cuál es
la peor pesadilla de Donald Trump no te
pierdas este vídeo que hicimos sobre la
incipiente alianza entre China y Rusia.
Pero bueno, respecto a este vídeo, respecto
a cómo vencer a los malos ¿Tú qué
crees? ¿Son útiles las estrategias que
hemos visto para derrotarles? ¿Crees que
la parte económica, el trato con la
población debería tener más
protagonismo en las políticas de seguridad
y antiterrorismo? Como siempre puedes
dejarnos tu opinión y tus impresiones de
los comentarios. Además, si este vídeo te
ha resultado interesante no
duda es el darle a like, y por supuesto
si aún no te has suscrito no
desaproveches esta ocasión: hoy tenemos
una promoción fantástica, un dos por
uno
y encima gratis. Hoy te puedes suscribir
a VisualPolitik y también a VisualPolitik
en inglés completamente
gratis.
Así que, ya sabes, no pierdas la ocasión.
Un saludo y hasta pronto.